how did you pitch that crotch torturing
to him it was crutch torturing me
it's moving when I walked out I thought
to myself wow you all treat each other
so horribly for basically two hours what
was your first reaction when you saw all
of the different things that a
character's are doing to each other and
the way they're all kind of playing each
other
I remember being quite taken aback when
I saw the film just how elevated the
tension became for me because you know
I'm in the film and I knew what was
gonna happen and that bored a scene I
was like this with John like that
watching it was just so intense and
sorry about your like getting him back
does to be in the film well there's a
lot of torture scenes here as well
particularly in your character Benicio
what happens with you and the other
actors in those scenes once Danny yells
cut and you've just basically tortured
someone are you well yeah we're bring
M&Ms and Oreo cookies and feed them some
candy I don't believe in doing anything
without telling the other actor so you
know you you're as humane as possible
they will not survive
the knee did you want to take a decent
amount of time in between takes of those
intense scenes or did you have Benicio
and his co-stars just go right back into
it it was an intense moments but that
they were ready to do it what I was
amazed is how they were able to find
ways to express that in a very fresh and
powerful way who would you say is the
most badass in real life of the three of
you here we can see that thank you